supposedly a car is gonna meet us here a
truck is gonna meet us here you think so
is this them so they say look you could
consider working even if you've been
exposed as long as you have a mask and
by the way we don't necessarily have
enough masks so within those guidelines
as well they say bandanas and scarves
could potentially be considered to be
used as well.you scarves and bandanas
I'm not gonna let my friends that are
working on the frontlines nurses doctors
CMAs that are seeing treating patients
to go and get scarves and hope that that
somehow protects them from this virus
I'm gonna do what I can what I can is
getting these masks yes I'm gonna take
to the streets in just a moment but
first what masks am I talking about I'm
talking about n95 masks not these not
these these why do I want these long
story short n95 masks protect medical
workers by filtering out at least 95% of
particulates in the air they fit very
close to the face and actually needs to
be fit tested by staff as opposed to
surgical masks which hang loose and
don't provide nearly the same protection
okay so hospitals are short on these
special masks but if they can't track
them down what hope do I have well n95
masks aren't only for doctors
construction workers and painters use
them as well when it became clear that
the world was gonna need lots of n95
masks people started scooping them up
quickly thereby inflating the price by a
lot like 700 percent a lot and while
hospitals don't have the ability to seek
these masks out and negotiate I do now
this is very polarizing yes people
should not be rewarded for profiting off
a crisis but desperate times call for
desperate measures and I desperately
want it to protect my colleagues and I
which brings us to day one she told me
you have 3m masks available
what's the expiration date on that in 95
3m masks so they're good and the cost of
the n95 mask and where are the masks
there
are you coming give me five high five
for masks high five for masks come on
high five
as it happened bear knew something we
did it this day was not gonna go as
planned
check out this truck that's gonna
deliver some masks 20 feet of some
horsepower that's gonna get us there
safely and deliver these masks to keep
our doctors and nurses healthy someone
scratched it let's do it where are we
getting the pickup yeah Oh high quality
wipers and we've arrived where we're
getting these masks from and I'm not
gonna lie it feels really strange and
Shady supposedly a car is gonna meet us
here a truck is gonna meet us here you
think so
like I'm so slow through here
is this them I mean this has to be them
no no they're wearing masks and there's
three of them and there's they have
their hazards on we don't have a side
what's this side well they just come out
and start throwing masks it looks like
they're gonna make a right turn perfect
thank you all right so it looks like we
have this quote-unquote UPS truck that's
about to deliver these masks I don't
know if it's it but I hope it's it
because we've been waiting here for a
few hours now and I desperately want to
get these masks to where they can be
useful I hope it pulled over that's not
the thing ya think this is the winner
I don't think so cuz he's not slowing
down dammit
alright so it's like our three waiting
for these masks I hope this is not a
fiction fictional mask situation because
I've already paid $15,000 deposit to get
them but we can't locate the truck
driver it was in fact the fictional mask
situation sort of the truck never showed
up and another bye partner of initial
guy showed up and informed us that guy
number one screwed up the delivery date
as it happens the shipment was due to
arrived the following day at a different
location
anyway they apologized profusely and we
made arrangements to meet on day two I'm
driving now to like a foreign location
these masks and we're not going to get
the full amount that we've required but
at least we're getting some fingers
crossed I'm getting really frustrated
already at this point the goal is at
least to get half the masks today and
then figure out what we're doing rest of
the week but that will least get us
through a couple of weeks of testing do
how is late warehouse right now Michael
just getting this ease some of your
strain with ordering of course
everything we can get our hands on will
help the situation but people need to
understand that these need to be
reserved for the medical community they
are to prevent someone from catching the
virus who's dealing with a critical
patient that's it oh how naive I was
I was playing right into the hustler
handbook they gave me half the
merchandise and a taste of success I was
feeling good this thing was starting to
turn around but all of this was just
priming me for the curveballs that were
to come on day three I just saw some
doctors performing tests on patients
just wearing surgical masks
I saw nurses swabbing a patient's nose a
famous influencer wearing a surgical
mask this is putting them at risk we
don't need to do that first of all not
everybody needs to be tested at least
right now because it's not that we're
gonna run out of testing kits the real
issue is the safety of the providers
meaning the nurses and the doctors and
the CMAs but then also the environment
if they're walking into an office and
they're sick they can be contaminating
everyone around them so it's not so much
the shortage of kits anymore it's more
about getting the personal protective
equipment and figuring out the logistics
of how to conduct these tests later
today we're gonna be showing you a drive
through testing site that's being done
right and they're gonna be using some of
the personal protective equipment I'm
buying so I'm really excited to show
that to you guys but
on the journey now alright we've arrived
at the location to get the masks we're
gonna take them directly to the
healthcare providers that need them
we already got a few offices lined up
some drive throughs hospitals all that
let's make it happen as I walked into
the warehouse discrepancies in pricing
arose and I rush to get guy number one
and guy number two to talk it through
just to confirm and replay back
everything initially you and I discussed
you told me the masks are 750 apiece
I asked if you can do $7 a piece you
said yes yesterday I paid 750 apiece
which I don't care I pay the extra fifty
cents not a promise honestly I was just
no longer comfortable
luckily the day prior I was able to buy
twenty seven thousand dollars worth of
masks so I jumped back in the van and
headed to one of the testing sites where
my first batch was already in use hi
everybody I'm here today to walk you
through what it's like to come to a
drive through testing site to be tested
for Cova 19 I know a lot of people are
very anxious and I know this is a very
scary time but these are great sites to
help people
safely quickly and securely and so we
want to alleviate any sort of anxiety
about this and we're gonna walk you
through and drive you through actually
what it's like for a real patient
patients come in if they already have an
appointment and they've already had the
order so they've been screened to make
sure that they meet the criteria that
are set out by the CDC and the
Department of Health to get the tests
we're gonna have dr. Mike keep his
windows up at all time dr. light with
your windows up are you schedule an
appointment today
I'm gonna make sure that dr. Mike is on
our schedule yes you are let's wave you
through at this time the patient will be
held here until they make sure that the
nurse in the tents is free to do the
swab and once they do they're gonna say
Mike dr. Mike continue to keep your
window up until you get to the nurse at
the end of the 10th drive straight
through until the end of the 10th the
nurse will tell you what it's time to
roll down your window and at this point
the patient will stop the nurse will put
on her appropriate personal protective
equipment and give the instructions to
the patient to roll down the window to
have the swab done any recommendations
for patients at home who are maybe
having mild symptoms do they need to get
tested do asymptomatic patients get
tested do we have any guidelines on that
so unfortunately right now given some of
our constraints like we just talked
about patients who are healthy so
they're not elderly they don't have any
luck any underlying medical conditions
and they feel well they can care for
themselves and they can eat and drink
they're really not being recommended to
be tested at this time for patients who
do meet the criteria so anything above
that of course we recommend that they
get tested and if they're critically ill
of course that they go try and get
emergency services as I just did a
little box patient example here if I was
to get the test done how long would I
expect to wait for the results so at our
testing facility the lab we're using
takes about three to four days for the
results to come back
they are variable there are some tests
which I know come back within a few
hours some that take 24 to 48 and some
that take 3 to 4 and some that take even
longer so I think it ranges a spectrum
but a few days all right this is why we
did this entire journey to get personal
protection equipment for those who are
on the frontlines individuals who are
going to be working a testing site just
like this people need to get tested but
doctors nurses all health professionals
need to be protected that's why I went
on this journey to get these at 95 masks
sites like this are going to be using
them hospitals are going to be using the
medical office are gonna be using them :
at 19 I learned not anxious alert not
anxious doesn't just mean alert with the
news reports and information that's
being put out by the CDC the w-h-o it
means also being alert to what your
body's symptoms are so if you start
getting worsening symptoms please
contact a health care provider before
going to the office before
we're going to the ER so they can guide
you on how to not get people sick that
are around you if you have any medical
supplies or anything that you think
could be used as medical supplies
contact your local hospital see if they
can be of help because those supplies
are truly truly in demand and we need
them now more than ever and please stop
buying masks for personal use I've put
together a couple of playlists for you
here and here check them out as always
stay happy and healthy
[Music]